getting back to the writer in this
technique
the whole technique is called the travis
technique but this part of the travis
technique is the interrogation process
and
it's it's a process of interrogating the
characters it's a very
um highly defined process and technique
but it's something that i've shown a lot
of writers how to do
and i have this like this one workshop i
did
in munich i think i've done a couple
places where it's just called meet your
characters before you write your
script and i've had
writers come in and say okay i've got
this story i said okay you know give me
a paragraph
a paragraph short paragraph on each
character tell me what the story is
okay give me a paragraph on each
character and just a short paragraph so
i go
and we'll take you know typical family
drama i got the husband the wife a
couple of kids a couple of neighbors and
this is the story and that's the thing i
say okay now i've read this
and i know this there's a group of
actors in the room and they haven't read
any of it
right or i can give it to them and then
i start interrogating
these actors and turn them into those
characters and within
minutes the writer is sitting there in
the room with all his characters
talking to each other engaging with each
other and we did this
once in munich on a full project and
then the writer would say to me
well these i want to see what happens if
these two characters have this situation
happen so i said okay then i would
just work with the two act two actors
and put them into that scene
this is an unwritten scene and the
writer is going there's my scene
well there's the idea of a scene and but
the idea now this gets back to the
collaboration if writers could think
about i'm developing this story what
would happen if
in the process i met with a few writers
i mean a few actors
worked with them allowed them to be
these characters for a moment so i could
sort of
get a sense of them outside of my head
but viscerally in front of me
and then let the actors go home and i'll
keep working in other words
meet the characters one of the
greatest untapped resources we have in
this business
seriously which we very rarely use is
the creative
imagination of actors we do a terrible
thing
we write a script for a year two years
months director comes along gets an idea
producer comes along you know now
everybody's got an idea and then they
start casting and what we're doing in
the casting is we're trying to find
those actors
and there are thousands of them the
right actors to fit into the little
boxes that we've created which are
called characters
and we find the best actor to fit in
that box and then basically ask them to
play that character and that's the way
it works
what would happen if you brought in some
actors long before that
and this is what we'll be doing in this
weekend bring in actors long before that
and say okay we're still in the
development process we don't know where
we don't even know quite where this
story is going to go maybe or how it's
going
but bring actors in and allow them to
use their creative imagination the
creative abilities to
totally inhabit these characters for a
while
so you can see what's going to happen
why not you know it's like building a
car
bmw does not build just a beautiful car
a fast car anything
and then put it on the market and sell
it it tests it
over and oh every part of that car is
tested and tested and tested
you know to see that it's going to work
right but we we don't test anything
suddenly many times the first time
a writer and i've heard this from some
writers hear their
words come out of an actor is when we're
shooting the film
i'm like oh that's ridiculous or in the
theater if the writer got jettisoned
before
yeah yeah yeah if the writer is lucky
enough to be there yeah like many times
i did when i was working with a with
mark rydell and he would ask me
i did this process with a full script
and we'd we'd work for
just one day on the script with the
characters and then i'd do a reading at
the end of the day and he'd come and see
the reading and the one writer was a
very well known writer
came and sat and watched this it was in
a theater he just heard a reading of his
screenplay
and he went oh my god he says i've never
heard my script read before like this
it's always the first reading after it's
all cast he says but now that i've heard
it he says i
now i know what it needs and now i know
where the problems are
so this this way of working with actors
earlier in the process
as part of the development exploratory
process is really crucial
and one of the things we're doing in
this weekend is
we're getting scenes from
two different participants in the
workshop that will be there and we're
using those to go through this whole
process
so we're not just saying oh look at this
great performance in 12 years a slave or
in nebraska or whatever
we're taking this raw script or these
scenes
with the writer there and we're going to
be talking first about what goes in and
discussing it but then
they're going to see and the entire all
the participants are going to see these
principles applied to something
that isn't finished and isn't production
ready and so on to see how this can be
done
and see the transformation of those
scenes
going through this entire collaborative
process
beginning to end i think that's going to
be
exciting to me because i haven't had
that experience before
of getting to do that with one of my
clients and taking it all the way to
let's mold this with a director and by
pulling the characters out of an actor